washington journal continues
the book is titled the politics of
resentment and joining us from madison
wisconsin is the author political
science professor catherine cramer
thanks very much for being with us here
on c-spin we appreciate it
thank you for having me so what was the
genesis of the book why did you write it
i wrote it because i study public
opinion i'm a professor at uw madison
university wisconsin madison
and i was interested in the way people
make sense of politics the way they
interpret politics and i live in
wisconsin i love wisconsin and i was
very interested to hear what people in
the state were thinking and also
how they were thinking about our
university so
wisconsin was sort of out of convenience
and just by chance but it ended up being
a pretty fascinating place to study
public opinion especially in light of
what happened with the results with
wisconsin and michigan and pennsylvania
flipping from democrat to republican
giving donald trump the presidency you
write a lot about governor scott walker
and the recall petitions that he faced
as the republican governor in the badger
state let me share with our audience
part of what you wrote in your book the
politics of resentment you say my window
to the way of politics of resentment
works in wisconsin this is a state in
which the debate over the appropriate
role of government has played out
prominently since 2000 it has been a
partisan battleground you can see the
push and pull of partisan fights here in
multiple ways
so explain
sure
well wisconsin as many people know has
been a swing state for some time and it
sort of has this independent streak in
our political culture
um and the the the battle of you know
what is the appropriate role of
government has been playing out here
as
people you know
at times we voted for democrats at times
we voted for republicans
and what i heard in my travels around
the state was a lot of discontent with
government and and from a wide range of
people and in that kind of context it it
makes a pretty
uh possible for politicians of many
different stripes to come in and make an
argument for change that appeals to
people
so we're we're not unique in that
respect and that's happening in a lot of
places of the country obviously
but we are our election
of governor walker in 2010 was
a flashpoint if you will in some ways
and drew a lot of national attention so
we've been we've been a window to things
going on in other parts of the country
for some time now you break down many of
the socio-economic issues and uh the
income issues that affect uh wealthier
americans and also the divide between
rural and urban in the book you write
the following when you consider how much
the very top income earners may compare
to the bulk of the population income
inequality in the united states looks
even worse and here are the figures you
put on the screen the average u.s income
for the top 1 percent
1.1 million dollars and for the bottom
ninety percent it was just twenty nine
thousand one hundred forty three dollars
a year
quite a disparity in your mind
yeah it's quite a disparity and i would
say most people in the u.s are aware
that there is a disparity but the extent
of it is often pretty shocking to people
why is the middle class shrinking
well that's a great question
i would say you know it's partly um when
you have income inequality of that
magnitude
that means that there's a smaller and
smaller group of people who have a
larger and larger portion of the wealth
and so that means you know
less wealth for a middle class
but also clearly it has something to do
with the shifts in our economy and the
nature of manufacturing and so what
we've considered middle class jobs for
so long um have changed um and and to
some extent just cease to exist so
it's partly you know the nature of the
jobs available and also just the shifts
in who's holding wealth in the in the
population
our guest is katherine kramer she is a
professor at the university of wisconsin
in madison wisconsin and we are dividing
our phone lines differently for this
segment if you live in rural america 202
000 for those of you
outside the urban areas and those living
in cities urban residents is 202 748
8001. let's talk about the election of
donald trump and the impact in wisconsin
what did you see firsthand and did you
sense that trump could win wisconsin
um to you know to be honest i was
surprised that trump won wisconsin
partly because i was following the polls
at the end of the campaign like everyone
else and put a lot of stock in them
but
in the lead up to the election i
definitely heard a great deal of support
for donald trump
and
support that probably
would surprise a lot of
people who were not supporting donald
trump and supporting hillary clinton or
bernie sanders even earlier
and oftentimes that support was people
acknowledging
some of the distasteful things that
donald trump said on the campaign trail
and nevertheless strongly supporting him
and i think that mix of attitudes is
somewhat surprising to people who oppose
him so strongly so
i wasn't as surprised as a lot of people
was probably the the fairest thing to
say the one phrase that you alluded to
earlier and you write a lot about in
your book is the term rural
consciousness and in the book you say
rural consciousness is a term i am using
to describe a strong sense of identity
as a rural person combined with a strong
sense that rural areas are what you call
the victims of injustice the sense that
rural areas do not get their fair share
of power do not get their respect or the
resources that they feel are necessary
the particular puzzle i focus on in this
book is why people prefer less
government when they might seemingly
benefit from more of it
right and i know
your viewers who live in rural areas or
have experience in rural areas will kind
of laugh that that's uh laugh at that
that that's a revelation at all i mean
basically what i was hearing was
something that people have been talking
with each other about in small
communities and rural places around the
country for some time and it's it's this
feeling of you know people in places
like this we're just on the short end of
the stick
we
don't know no one pays attention to us
we don't get our fair share of resources
it's this view that you know we
are not respected actually by folks who
live in the cities and decision makers
who live in the cities and that that
view was a surprise to me but in my
interactions with folks you know as i've
been talking about that point of view
and and sharing my books with the folks
i've spent time with
their
their reaction to me sometimes is well
no kidding lady
so i'm sure some of your viewers are are
familiar with what i'm talking about but
as you write in the book that voters are
looking for somebody that they can
connect with and my question donald
trump who lives in trump tower on the
68th floor is a billionaire and yet
seemingly able to connect with wisconsin
voters in a way that hillary clinton was
not able to do so so explain that how
was donald trump able to appeal to those
voters
i think what happened is donald trump
came along and said you know you're
right you're right to be upset you're
right to think that you're not getting
what you deserve
and he also gave to people sort of an
explanation of what was going on in the
world that would leave them feeling like
they're not getting their fair share i
mean he talked about trade when he
talked about the economy
and made claims about where the jobs
that seem to have disappeared where
they've gone and he also gave people
kind of targets to blame so immigrants
for example right talking about
immigrants coming in and taking jobs and
so basically he said you know you're
right you're right to be upset you are
deserving you are hard-working americans
and what you deserve is going to people
who are less deserving and so he you
know he lives in trump tower in the
middle of new york city
but his message appealed to people who
live very very far from that center of
wealth and power let's bring in our
colors and our c-span radio listeners
with katherine cramer who's the author
of the politics of resentment she's
joining us on this friday from madison
wisconsin and that's where our first
caller is from keith good morning
good morning i was one of those who
marched up to the capitol with the other
other people who were protesting the
attacks on public sector workers
we were making the argument that
the high pay of public sector workers
would
boost the pay of all workers because it
was it was kind of like a race to the
top
and what i think this author does and i
see i saw her on c-span giving a talk at
the library in madison
i actually watched it on the c-span
and
what she does is she kind of dismisses
the whole issue of race it's is central
to
solidarity of the working class it makes
it much more difficult for us to
organize long class lines when the
owners and the politicians who are
basically
bought and paid for by the owners they
are pitting workers against one another
a prime example of this was in scott
walker
he was caught on video talking to diane
hendricks one of the richest people in
the state he claimed he was going to
quote uh pit workers against each other
i mean he said it explicitly it wasn't
like he was it was this is some kind of
conspiracy he he actually admitted he
was going to pit workers against each
other he's going to put
black workers against white workers he's
going to pit
women against men he was going to pit
public secular workers against private
sector workers
and
he succeeded you know he succeeded
against you know pitting workers against
each other and
and now we've seen 30 years of this of
workers being pitted against one another
and uh that's why we've
suffered a decline in our living
standards the working class
he thank you for the call from wisconsin
we'll get a response katherine kramer
sure thanks keith for the call and
thanks for bringing up the issue of race
and i think let's just dive right into
that because it's hugely important so i
guess i mean i disagree that i dismiss
the the role of race and i actually
think it's it's pretty important here
and here's what i have to say on that i
think
that racism is sort of the baseline
where we need to start with our our
discussions of
controversies over who should get what i
mean
from the moment that we had our federal
government has been talking about
redistribution race has been a part of
the story so shortly after the civil war
when our federal government had the
power and the resources to actually
distribute or redistribute
it race was used as a way to divide
people amongst each other basically
white farmers from
freed african americans and
we you know clearly as a country have
never really come to terms
with that
and it remains a part of our discussions
about redistribution and who should get
what
and what i do in my book is try to
to to ease into i shouldn't say ease but
to come around to the question of race
as carefully as possible because what i
don't want to happen is for people to
hear what i have to say or read my book
and come away and say
see those people in rural america
they're just a bunch of racists
and leave it at that because it's so
much more complex than that and we're
not ever going to repair the divisions
in this country if we simply keep
dividing along very simple lines and so
the complexity as i see it is this
that when people are talking about who's
deserving and feeling like they are
deserving and they're not getting what
their fair share is and that it's going
to people who are undeserving racism is
in those conversations because
unfortunately we have stereotypes about
who's hard-working and who is not in
this country that are often very
racialized meaning people of color often
are attributed with laziness more than
white folks
but
when people are talking about those
people in the city those lazy people in
the cities they are oftentimes talking
about me too so they're often talking
about white professionals and
understanding the ways in which class
and race and region are intertwined is
really
important for figuring out how we
actually come together as a country and
for the purposes of organizing workers
it's helpful to understand
those dividing lines so i really
appreciate bringing up the topic of race
because i in no way
mean or want to skirt it because i agree
it's
central to this whole conversation the
subtitle to catherine cramer's book
reads as follows rural consciousness in
wisconsin and the rise of scott walker
the book the politics of resentment and
keith had mentioned her appearance on
c-span 2's book tv if you want to watch
that as well and all of our non-fiction
book tv programming you can check it out
online anytime either through the home
page at cspan.org or go to
booktv.org of course a reminder c-span 3
this weekend is american history tv so
full offering as we prepare for the
holiday weekend let's go to don also
from wisconsin good morning in wappin
wisconsin in the more rural area go
ahead please
good morning thank you for taking my
call c-span i appreciate it
i'm hoping that you don't cut me off
um i have a question about resentment
and wonder if that could have anything
to do with possibly the 13th amendment
of forced servitude
and people
forcing people to do illegal activities
like the 23 corporations that embezzled
workers retirement assets
and wisconsin downplayed it by
doing a secret john doe cover-up
i think
part of the resentment that i've heard
in
you know many
many communities around the state
does have to do with perceptions of
government corruption or perceptions of
government
not being
not being attentive to people like me so
to the extent that people perceive that
government is allowing corruption or or
government government
and workers or elected officials are
doing it themselves yes that definitely
feeds into a resentment of why am i
working so hard to make ends meet when
people are are
breaking the rules in order to get more
um so i think that those perceptions of
government
being broken come in many forms and i
think what you just mentioned is is one
form professor kramer let me read three
tweets two comments one with a question
first from tj who says donald trump
would fill up stadiums while hillary
could not fill a high school gym that
was the most accurate poll not the bias
polls given on tv and another comment
from dean who says trump used propaganda
to brainwash the simple-minded so first
on those two comments your reaction
well
in terms of who got the bigger crowds
um
the trump campaign was
had an element of entertainment that
drew
crowds in person and also in attention
to news stories related to the trump
campaign
so i um
you know was that
was that enthusiae was that a lack of
enthusiasm for hillary clinton or was it
just
really heightened interest in donald
trump i mean i'm saying that a little
bit wrong but i think part of the you
know the draw of big crowds for donald
trump was a recognition that at almost
every campaign event something
newsworthy happened
so we have to keep that in mind
and also you know appealing to the
simple-minded
i have a lot to say on that
so
it's a common you know it's a common
notion that people who voted for donald
trump were fooled or ignorant or
um not knowledgeable or less educated
but
when i when i go and spend time with
people in my field work who i know voted
for trump these days
they ask me
how is it that all those smart students
at uw-madison voted for hillary clinton
what is wrong with them what are they
not getting
and so my point of bringing that up is
that
on both sides we are wondering what's
wrong with people who voted for the
other candidate
and to attribute other people's choices
to ignorance
kind of overlooks the fact that we all
subjectively define our self-interests
now i don't want to ignore though the
extent to which many of the things
donald trump said on the campaign trail
have been proven by fact checkers to be
inaccurate in other words lies
and
that you know that's important
and deserves attention and you might say
okay folks who voted for a candidate who
gave outright lies isn't there an
element of ignorance to that well
there's definitely an element of
misinformation
so my point i guess in general what i
want to say is
yeah we have to pay attention to where
they're in our inaccuracies in our
campaigns but i think we should be
cautious about explaining other people's
votes as the lack of ignorance i mean as
a presence of ignorance
and this is a tweet from max by the way
you can send us a tweet at c-span w-j he
wants to know were you in contact with
the hillary rodham clinton campaign to
lend perspective if so were they
receptive to your ideas
i was not
i don't you know my job is not to
consult with campaigns my job is to help
everybody better understand
the american public
um so i guess the the answer is no i was
not in contact from dayton ohio lynn is
next and again we're dividing our phone
lines between urban and rural callers
good morning lynn
good morning uh it just seems to me that
uh
people uh here in ohio
near the end of the uh
time to vote were bombarded with the uh
uh fbi report
that made injustice seem as though it
was uh something that hillary clinton
was uh too engulfed in
whereas uh you didn't have a significant
uh amount of uh authoritative figures as
far as donald trump's misguidedness
or right out wrong and lies
that he was telling the public
which uh pretty much verified that
uh
she was going to be
more of a
chance of being
further involved in more injustice
as far as the government and
the
corporate figures
have done to the middle class for
over 30 years now
we'll get a response thank you for the
call from dayton
yeah um that's good
it's a good perspective to hear
i'm not really sure i have much more to
say on top of what the caller said so
thank you for the call thank you we'll
go to jimbo joining us from alabama what
part of the state do you live in jimbo
and north alabama about 30 miles south
of huntsville go ahead with your
question or comment
yes i thank you for the opportunity to
express my views
i'd like to ask
kramer
what does she think uh as far as uh the
uh
uh material injustice being being uh
done to the big big population in the
united states millions of people
uh uh because of
the consistent and persistent attacks on
labor unions uh in the past i've i'm a
vietnam era veteran and
and i i see that the uh
the labor unions have almost dwindled to
right on down almost to nothing
and all of the
you know the tax money which is is
becoming more and more fleeting
uh because uh
and now they're doubling down i see uh
i see the they want to double down on
tax breaks for the wealthy
uh what is the working poor going to do
in the future
it's a great concern to raise i mean
labor unions are a really important set
of organizations that represent workers
interests and without
labor unions there aren't there isn't a
structure
that's you know in place to to to
represent workers
and i definitely hear a lot of concern
in my field work about labor unions from
folks i mean honestly sometimes it's
people who were a part of a union or
currently are and and perceive
corruption within their union so
sometimes there's people complaining
about their unions but oftentimes
especially among retirees who were part
of a union i hear people talking about
how
how grateful they were to be represented
by a union and how grateful
they are to now be able to be in
retirement and have you know a decent
quality of life
um so concern about labor unions is
something that's that's very widespread
and labor unions are not popular in
public opinion polls
but for people who have been represented
by labor unions i generally find just
a whole lot of gratitude that they were
able to have someone fighting on their
behalf
a tweet from sandy beach we get a lot of
tweets from sandy and now we know this
individual lives in wisconsin writing
the following it wasn't only trump
wisconsin rural voters like me
also voted to defeat radical liberals in
madison check out the state outcomes
catherine kramer can you elaborate
yeah that's true i mean so our state
government now is republican and um and
the the um she may be referring also to
you know
the fact that governor walker or scott
walker has been our governor since 2010
um so yes that's right that um outs what
we sometimes call out state wisconsin or
rural wisconsin has been
voting for republicans pretty
consistently now for some years
and kybell who says i've lived in big
cities and now in a very rural town
thank god for now i feel sorry for city
dwellers
they are missing life
let me go back to your book katherine
kramer you write the following in an
atmosphere of resentment it is tough to
take the high road our current politics
you say gives a little incentive for
elected officials to pursue such
behavior it is a time that those of us
with the power to vote demanded of them
what are you referring to
well
i think you know it's easy to understand
why a politician might tap into the
divides among us right make us
draw our attention to the ways in which
we don't like
other groups in the population if if
that's you know
politically advantageous
and
they're really
in my mind that kind of that
use of resentment the only way to cut
through it is for
people somebody to rise above it i mean
ideally it would be a political leader
who refuses to use that kind of rhetoric
that puts us against one another
but it may also have to come from
ordinary citizens and voters who refuse
to
vote
for candidates or take stances on
policies based on
you know us versus them
ideas but instead on the merits of the
policy or on the merits of the the
policies that the candidate is
representing
that's a you know that's a tall order
but it is my hope and i um
in my classes at the university of
wisconsin-madison i regularly talk with
students about these types of issues and
i see in our young people a desire for
kind of a higher type of politics in
which we're not pitting ourselves
against one another but we're trying to
figure out ways to make everybody better
off and to refuse to vote on the basis
of resentment toward one another
the book the politics of resentment our
guest catherine cramer joining us from
madison and ray in raleigh north
carolina good morning welcome to the
conversation
good morning how are you
we're fine thank you well
my question is this over the years i've
been working on here i'm all business
and i see foreigners come to this
country where americans have to train
them and then americans lose their jobs
but as an african-american what upsets
me is whenever it's time to vote they
come to our community but they spend 133
billion dollars or more a year on
illegal immigration that could be going
to our communities we have to take care
of the children once they get here
my question is why would they say [ __ ]
in mexico why would they just shut the
border down say nobody can come in and
out through cars bring guns back bring
money back just cut it off because
they're letting their borders be
overwhelmed that they come to their
country to get to ours if we stop that
then we train americans instead of
fighting illegal immigration that money
can be used for businesses to train
americans and be lost it costs us a lot
less thank you thank you ray
well
i guess i have a lot to say in response
to that one is
um
i think there's a lot of misconceptions
in the extent of illegal immigration and
just
you know the motivation for people to
come here
and
um
the fact is that
a lot of businesses i mean i'm speaking
here with wisconsin in mind i mean there
are there are businesses in my state
that are grateful for immigration i'm
thinking in particular of the dairy
industry
um
and i um
i'm not
i should distinguish here between people
who
don't have their papers or undocumented
immigrants and immigrants who have
arrived here legally but i guess my
my main response to that question is
this is kind of a case in point right
that we
people are struggling to make ends meet
and
so often we're we're turning to
say
this you know
immigrants undocumented immigrants and
assuming that it's because of them
that were struggling and i just
i just find that very sad and um
it's
not
it's it's the kind of political argument
that
is not about okay how do we ensure that
everybody has a decent quality of life
and instead is shifting our anxieties on
toward blaming a particular
group of people that i
just i really don't have a better
response than that that that i i think
that that line of thinking is getting us
nowhere productive
let's go to anthony north st paul
minnesota good morning welcome to the
program katherine kramer who's joining
us from madison wisconsin
i am so glad that i got a chance to talk
about this subject um my uh my take on
it is
of threefold
minimum wage americans vote against
their own best interest when they
elected donald trump he wants to lower
the minimum wage
okay and then a lot of people have
screamed about food stamps a lot of
people you're not getting a whole lot of
food from food stamps i mean some people
are getting fifty dollars a month try to
live off of fifty dollars a month for
one person and another thing is that i
continue hearing about people talking
about uh minorities getting food stamps
and and subsidies there are more white
people in america on these on these
programs than there are blacks in in the
whole country i mean the entire black
race here but the thing that i really
wanted to say is this country needs to
start trying to address racism because
this has been going on too long and
racism is not something that children
are born with we teach our children
these things and then and we have to
understand that if you want to succeed
in life you work hard you don't just
climb up make yourself feel better
because you put somebody else down that
doesn't help your situation at all but
we need to start spending less money on
two billion we spend almost a billion
dollars uh every year on defense and the
next 10 countries don't we need to start
spending that money on education here in
our country and that thing about donald
trump talking about blocking immigrants
that plan that he has it says whether
those those jobs are 25 million jobs
from what i understand they're going to
have to import people because we don't
educate our kids well enough if you look
at the systems away around the country
the water symptoms are bad the school
systems are bad and now we're getting
people in that want to start digging
holes digging up coal and everything you
know the thing about it is and i hate to
say it but if a person wants to go and
get black long and and that's all
they're thinking about is a short time
um deal for their lives what about their
children anthony thank you we'll get a
response professor kramer
yeah thank you for the call
uh several things i want to comment on
there just the the notion that we
haven't dealt with racism and we need to
deal with racism i
agree with 100 percent
so thanks
and also with respect to education
just a really key central issue and what
has really interested me
and my field work in wisconsin is just
the it's it's a pervasive sense that
people want a high quality of education
for their kids or their youngsters in
their community
and what i find really interesting i
think really important for our debates
about whether we're going to put funding
into education or not is that there's a
perception that
in many of the smaller communities i
spend time in that of course we value
education and it's really important to
us but if we pay in if we're asked to
pay higher taxes for education that
money is not going to come back to our
community
and so there's this sense that people
value education yet they don't believe
that higher taxes is actually going to
improve education for people like them i
think that's a really important
sentiment to pay attention to
but i agree with the caller that
education is central to progress in in
any society and
i'm you know
obviously
i believe in education i'm a university
professor and i wouldn't devote my life
to it if i didn't
and i'm the kid very proud kid of two
public school teachers so
um
you know just speaking personally i'm
with you i think education is essential
and where we need to
put some um
we need to value it
our conversation with katherine kramer
part of a week-long series here in the
washington journal as we bring you some
of the leading authors that we have
featured this past year on c-span 2's
book tv and in our sunday q a program
you teach political science and history
i presume at the university of wisconsin
what are your classes
i teach mainly political science so i
teach
public opinion political communication
political psychology and just this
semester i'm just winding up a class on
citizenship it's called citizenship
democracy and difference and it's what
we call a service learning class which
is a class in which the students are
engaged in the community as part of the
coursework as another kind of a text in
the class so they're learning um through
working with the local city government
or with a local community center
about how to put their ideas of good
citizenship into practice
so
hello to the students it's been it's not
been an awesome course an extraordinary
semester and this is a tweet from jan
who uh playing on the title of your book
she says the resentment vote is out of
the box it will never be put back in
that's the big question right now right
will it
i certainly hope it will
because
basing a democracy on resentment it does
not bode well for the future
joe from crystal lake illinois good
morning
good morning and tell us where that's
located in relation to chicago
75 miles away from chicago okay go ahead
please
uh
number one
oh thanks for taking my call
number one the public school systems in
shambles i
i talked to college graduates and uh
it's it's like talking to people that
just
are in the middle of their freshman year
in high school
and
and
i've had many people in my generation
i'm 75 years old
uh
tell me that they're sick and tired of
talk taking talking to adults that
and they gotta talk to them like like
they're babies and they can't have their
way
and another thing that really sounds
when you're a professor and you couldn't
see the momentum that donald trump was
getting across the nation
good grief i mean you got to go back to
school yourself anybody with any common
sense whatsoever would see all you would
have to do is drive through
the industrial parks
in rural america and there is nothing
but vacancies and empty buildings
so and one more thing
i heard
president obama talking to a crowd
prior to the election and he said and i
quote
he said i know you're going to be
disappointed when ptt passes and i send
jobs to vietnam
and the crowd just didn't say anything
they didn't they didn't applaud they did
they were they were like
i it's hard to explain i mean somebody
should have got up and started shouting
what do you mean you're sending the jobs
of vietnam
joe thank you we'll get a response
professor kramer
well i don't know
so much about that statement that
president obama's statement at that
event but um
i guess i'll i'll just refer the
the caller
not to assign you homework but
to refer you to my book in that actually
what my book is about is sort of the
momentum that you talk about
um us professors missing and about just
recognizing the extent of discontent
across
many parts of the nation and
particularly my focus was on wisconsin
but
thanks for encouraging me to go back to
school i love school
so i'm all in favor of it so thanks for
the call why do you think governor scott
walker's presidential bid ended so early
well
i don't know for sure but i think
part of it may have been that
he i mean he's done
extremely well here in wisconsin in
terms of gaining support
but i think going from kind of
being in the spotlight in a statewide
way to being in the spotlight in a
national way
it's a very different
set of concerns that you have to address
and just a different level of intensity
and
i think you know perhaps
that was just a
maybe too early of a jump for him i'm
not sure but also i think the nature of
this republican primary was
very different i mean with the
the
extensive field just the number of
candidates
um and also the presence of donald trump
i mean clearly he's a different kind of
politician who shook up this campaign in
many different ways and i think the way
in which
he drew a lot of the attention
to himself just from the start
meant that
what the other republican candidates
were dealing with was um you know trying
to make a name for themselves with in a
very very
small amount of air time basically
so it could be just the mix of those
things and probably other things that
i'm not aware of too quick question from
mary potter and again send us your
tweet at seaspend wj saying please ask
how twitter and social media affected
the outcome did you delve into that area
at all
um and sort of by asking people where
they're they're getting their
information but currently
i'm doubling into it with some great
colleagues here at uw-madison so devon
shaw and luke friedland chris wells and
mike wagner and i were all professors
here were fascinated in that very
question so i don't have a great answer
for you now but hopefully will in a
short amount of time a couple more calls
with our guest katherine cramer the
politics of resentment teresa joining us
from pittsburgh pennsylvania good
morning
yeah good morning
i am a vietnam veteran as well a white
woman
i lived in the country i've lived in the
city i've lived overseas i've lived in
many different places
the number one bias
probably all over the world is not race
it's gender
and i'm wondering why we're not talking
more about that
there is a different mentality in the
country versus the city and i've seen it
people don't trust women women don't
trust women
and i think this is something that we
need to think about
the reason why i believe trump
was voted in
was because there was a woman
running against him
people don't use their intelligence when
it comes to voting
a lot of people voted with their
emotions
and i believe that that's why trump won
and there is a difference between the
mentality of people who live in the
country and who live in the city
thank you teresa we'll get a response
thanks for bringing up gender
sister
it's a
i agree it's a huge issue and it's um
it's interesting how
little it was talked about in this
campaign and at the same time what a
massive role it played
and i don't think it's a coincidence
that
donald trump
and some of his you know
kind of shockingly
not
gender equal things that he said on the
campaign trail
um
that i it's not a surprise
it's not a coincidence that
um
he was running against the first you
know viable national party female
candidate
the contrast
i mean the
the dynamic that you mentioned just that
that people were uncomfortable with a
woman as president i think is something
that we really have to come to terms
with and public opinion polls say you
know that
an overwhelming majority of people say
that yes they would vote for
a female
candidate for president if that if if
it's a you know good candidate
and yet
um
i do think there are many ways in which
the the
the country was not willing to
elect a female president and here i
should back up to say
i'm thinking mainly here not of public
opinion polls because like i said public
opinion polls say that the majority of
voters are ready to vote for a woman for
president and yet i'm i'm thinking
mainly of my field work in which
um
this is there it's not a cross-section
of wisconsinites not a cross-section of
people the united states but i've often
been in conversations with people
talking about um both their perceptions
of hillary clinton and their very
negative perceptions of her
and their thoughts on how
having a woman as president just the
country and almost that exact phrasing
is just not ready for it yet
it's a you know
it is very interesting the way in which
we don't talk about it much
but it's a really
it's a big issue and it's it's present
even though we're not talking about it
derek our last caller from columbus ohio
good morning thank you for waiting
you're on with katherine kramer oh good
morning and good morning mrs kramer
i have a couple of comments and then a
question for you i will start
by
suggesting that uh
donald trump and his whole regime have
used for years and years and years the
same sort of methods that were used by
dictators all over the world
most especially adolf hitler comes to
mind where he creates red herrings
uh such as the the the people of islam
who who worship oslo or the mexicans
they get all these people who are
already uh prone to be anti-us
government uh pseudo-christians fall
patriots and and race haters of every
sort to make them the big demon bad guys
people buy into that they're they're
they're hoodwinked and bamboozled and
they can't see what is the best interest
for the country all the people of the
country they create a bad guy and most
people went towards that as far as
misogyny and and race and that sort of
thing i never understood how people both
democratic and republican are always
voting against their best interests or
they become apathetic and they don't
vote
so one comment off track is i like to
say that the character in your face
tells me that you're a fighter and
you've been fighting for a long time but
you're working against inalienable odds
i just want to make a comment that you
should keep
fighting the good fight there are those
of us around who really support your
philosophy
but my question to you and you may have
to write another book
to answer it in it entirely why are so
many people so beguiled and so full of
ignorance i guess that they can't see uh
the demon when it's coming i.e that
they're working against the interest of
all people and is it is it race is it
hatred is it they don't like the
government uh i
everybody knew that uh hillary is no
angel but she was a much better choice
than a donald trump and
not only the people who voted for trump
but the people who failed to vote for
hillary what what what do you think
caused that sort of thing and that's my
comment and merry christmas to everybody
derek thank you for the comments the
questions we'll get a response
yeah thanks for the call
um
um that's not a great way to start an
answer is it
i
i guess i'm pausing because i
i personally i found it helpful to
encourage myself to not
make jud
not assume that people are voting
against their interests because what i
know about interest is that
in the realm of politics
there's very
seldom
something that we can objectively define
as someone's true interest and
oftentimes we are
we are
defining our interests in pretty
subjective ways
and so that's kind of
an abstract way of saying
don't be quick to say
that people are voting against their
interests
if we're going to repair
if we're going to repair our country we
have to
understand why people are voting the way
that they are which i realize is the
root of your question why are people
voting the way that they are
and i think
um
much of the motivation that i have heard
in in people's voting for trump and
supporting trump
is the perception that the system is so
broken
that of course we need someone
who is saying that he's going to come in
and shake things up
and
change things drastically drain the
swamp if you will right
and part of that i mean the contrast
between trump and hillary clinton
on that dimension oftentimes these folks
are perceiving that hillary clinton is
part of the problems that she's been a
part of the federal government
in a way for for many years the 30 years
that donald trump often mentioned right
now i know that you're going to say in
response well okay donald trump is not
exactly draining the swamp so far so
aren't they voting against their
interests
again it's it's partly i mean
understanding
the nature of the depths of that
discontent that would lead people
to vote for someone even though there
are parts of what he is saying and
supporting that they don't agree with
um
it's
uh
it's a it's a mix of many things but for
me it's the the issue is just the level
of discontent
the feeling like
so many different kind of powerful
structures
and people are are against you
i think that feeling is what oftentimes
motivates people to vote for someone who
um other people see as destructive and
as c is someone who's going to take away
the rights
and the liberties of other people
[Music]
you're right though that there is a
whole
other book if not volumes of books to be
written on this this question it seems
to me to be kind of the central question
that we're facing right now
if you write that next book we would
love to have you back katherine kramer
the book is called the politics of
resentment a professor of political
science at the university of wisconsin
joining us from madison
thank you very much for being with us on
this friday we appreciate it
thank you for having me and thanks to
your callers
some news on this friday morning
overnight in case you're just waking up
that suspect linked to that horrific
incident in berlin